direct du luxembourg la psychologue et
psychothérapeute catherine verdi verdi
bonjour merci d'avoir ma accepté notre
invitation alors le confinement rester
chez soi cela angoisse beaucoup de
français beaucoup de stress comment
voilà cela doit-il être vécue est ce que
ce confinement peut être également un
danger pour la santé même si on doit
justement se préserver du coronavirus
alors il faut se préserver du courroux
navires us bien évidemment et rester
chez soi maintenant il faut aussi
préserver sa santé mentale comme vous
dites c'est vrai que les les émotions
elle elle fluctue en fonction des heures
là pour le moment que ce soit en france
à luxembourg ou en europe
c'est à dire qu'on passe d'un état a
battu à résigner là depuis hier soir
solidaires puis aujourd'hui et puis en
pleine préparation bien évidemment pour
une longue période
pour éviter pour éviter justement que la
santé mentale ne ce ne soit altérée
voilà un moral qui risque d'être en
baisse à provoquer des coups de blues
on a entendu le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner interdire totalement
tous les déjeuners de famille les
sorties entre amis
comment est-ce que voilà on peut faire
face à cela surtout les personnes qui
sont seules qui voilà qui sont seules
chez elles
comment est-ce qu'on peut gérer
justement ce confinement sur le plan
psychologique
effectivement c'est très très dur pour
les hommes pour l'épauler et par an pour
les personnes qui sont seules
il y a bien sûr tous les moyens
numériques tels que skype facetime et
autres pour garder le contact et il faut
garder le contact maintenant pour les
personnes qui sont en famille
les difficultés sont autres les
difficultés sont plutôt de l'ordre de
l'organisation au sein de la famille de
cette petite communauté qui se
retrouvent dans une promiscuité dont on
n'a pas forcément l'habitude alors c'est
un climat plutôt anxiogène
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on regarde la
télévision qu'on écoute les informations
on y échappe un assaut coronavirus et ce
qu'ils font sont détachés justement
essayer de se divertir
vous avez parlé des moyens des réseaux
sociaux par exemple de toute cette
nouveauté sur sur les systèmes
informatiques est ce que la télévision
la lecture quels conseils vous pourriez
donner aux français
il faut absolument commandé à instaurer
voilà pardon instaurer une routine
il faut se lever le matin même mettre
son réveil éventuellement s'habiller se
doucher déjeuner et avoir tout une
routine de travail par rapport aux
enfants par rapport à soi même il faut
pas du tout se laisser aller
il y effectivement tous les réseaux
sociaux qui sont là qui sont présents
pour nous aider pour nous accompagner
ce serait merveilleux j'ai vu que france
5 proposait ddd documentaire éducatif
pour les enfants durant l'après midi
donc ça c'est super et puis c'est un
temps pour essayer de se retrouver aussi
soit c'est à dire de lire d'écrire
d'écouter de la musique de regarder des
vieux films de faire les choses dont on
avait toujours envie parce qu'ils
travaillent parce qu on est stressé
parce qu'on est dans le mouvement est
bien là on est en mouvement
justement et c'est vrai que c'est pas
simple mais ça demande un certain temps
d'adaptation mais je suis persuadé que
chacun trouvera les solutions pour pour
lui et pour sa famille il ne faut pas
tomber dans la dépression et comme vous
le dites en se réveiller faire une
routine tous les jours pour passer cette
période qui va être un petit peu
difficile
pendant ces quinze jours en tout cas
merci beaucoup à catherine verdier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes psychologue et
psychothérapeute